Good morning, believe nation.
My name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe, and
I believe that entrepreneurs
will solve all of the major
problems of the world.
So today's message is act despite fear.
Over to you Elon Musk.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning.
♫ Entspresso keep me going.
- You are unusually fearless
and willing to go in the face
of other people telling
you something is crazy.
And I know a lot of pretty crazy people.
You still stand out.
Where does that come from, or how
do you think about making a decision
when everyone tells you
this is a crazy idea?
Or where do you get the
internal strength to do that?
- Well first of all I'd say,
I actually think I feel
fear quite strongly,
so it's not as though I just have
the absence of fear, I
feel it quite strongly.
But there are just times when
something is important enough,
that you believe in it enough,
that you do it in spite of fear.
- So speaking of important things.
- Like people shouldn't think I ...
People shouldn't think,
"I feel fear about this
"and therefore I shouldn't do it."
It's normal to feel
fear, like you'd have to,
there'd have to be
something mentally wrong
with you if you didn't feel fear.
- So you just feel it
and let the importance
of it drive you to do it anyway?
- Yeah, actually something that
can be helpful is fatalism to some degree.
If you just accept the probabilities
then that diminishes fear.
When starting SpaceX I
thought the odds of success
were less than 10%, and
I just accepted that
actually, probably I would
just lose everything,
but that maybe we would
make some progress.
If we could just move the
ball forward, even if we died,
maybe some other company
could pick up the baton
and keep moving it forward so
that would still do some good.
Yeah, same with Tesla.
I thought the odds of a car company
succeeding were extremely low.
- Fear is normal, it's part
of what makes you human.
You would not be human, or you'd have
some crazy condition
if you never felt fear.
I think the people who
say, "Don't be afraid,"
aren't giving you practical advice.
It's, "Be afraid, feel the fear,
"and then step into it and do it anyway."
And the more you get used to taking on
those fearful projects
that you're scared of,
the stronger you'll get, the
more resistance you'll get,
the higher tolerance you'll get
to do bigger, better,
bolder, badder things.
I think the trick though
is spotting the fear.
Here's what I think
happens to most people,
there's some opportunity that comes along,
there's some moment that comes along,
whether it's with a client,
or meeting somebody,
or an event, something comes along
that you're afraid of,
you're afraid of doing it,
that's going to stretch you beyond
what you've ever done before.
And then what you do is
you rationalize saying no.
"I don't have the money
to go to that event.
"I'm too busy to go out
"and do that thing right now."
You find the reason why
you can't go and do it.
You rationalize it, but really, deep down,
the reason is you're just afraid.
And until you spot the
fear, until you understand
that it's really just the fear,
then you're never going
to solve the problem.
So step one is understanding
when there is fear.
Step two is then stepping
into it and doing it anyway,
and a lot of the stuff
is just so subconscious.
You know, we as human beings are kind of
trained to, when we're afraid something's
going to go wrong, you have to be safe.
And so it's trying to catch that
subconscious action, and
proactively change it.
So an example for me, when I was starting
my YouTube channel, my
agent would tell me,
"You have to go out and
do videos in public.
"I want you to go out on the street
"and make your video in public."
My natural reaction
was fear, but I didn't catch it.
Initially it was, "The gear
won't be as good in public.
"I can't control the light settings.
"I'm going to be bouncing
around with the camera.
"It's not going to be a great experience
"for the people watching,
why would I do that?
I'm rationalizing a reason
why I don't have to do it,
where really I'm just afraid.
You could solve all those problems.
And he told me, "Stop being afraid
"and just go out and do it."
He cut through it and
let me see my own fear.
And so I did it, and when I first went out
and filmed in public I
took out, it was my phone
or my camera, I don't remember,
and I'm walking on the street,
and then the postman is there.
And so as soon as I see
the postman, I quiet down,
I put the camera away,
just walking normally.
And then when the postman
leaves, I'm back to filming.
And that time I noticed, I'm
doing it because I'm afraid.
And I got pissed, "Okay,
next time I got to speak up.
"Next time I got to do better."
And so I went out and forced
myself to go and do it again.
And I was walking past,
and there were these
construction workers, and instantly again
the panic sets in like,
"People are watching,
"there's construction workers."
I know they don't even
really care about me
and what I'm saying, what's
happening on the street.
But I forced myself through it.
It was awkward, it wasn't great.
I think I had to redo it again anyway,
but I took the step, I got better at it.
I recognized the fear,
and I jumped into it,
and now it's to the point
where I'll make videos
walking down the hall, I'll make videos
when I'm at Disneyland, Disney World.
I'll make videos in the
streets of anywhere,
and there's still a moment, even now,
after how many videos I've done,
there's still a moment
of, "Who's watching?"
I think it's natural and normal.
It's not as strong as it used
to be, and more importantly,
it doesn't limit me from doing
the things that I want to do.
And so spotting the fear,
and not rationalizing it away,
and not just doing what your
subconscious always does
that keeps you down where
you are is so important.
Being truthful that the
reason why you said no,
or you're not taking this opportunity,
is just because you're afraid.
And the answer to saying
no should never be
"Because I'm afraid."
You want to re-jig your
system, so whenever
that's the answer, "Because
I'm afraid to do it,"
now you have to do it.
Because you're afraid, now
you have to go out and do it.
And you build your muscle to get stronger
to take on new opportunities,
so you don't play safe
and play small for the rest of your life.
So the question of the day today is
I'm curious what's one
thing that you are afraid of
or recently were afraid of
that you want to tackle?
Be bold, be brave, leave it
down in the comments below.
I'm really curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick shout out
to Dave Lukas from Misfit Entrepreneur.
Dave, thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book, Your One Word.
I hope you enjoyed the read, man,
and I really appreciate the support.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
And I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning.
♫ Entspresso keep me going.
- The only way to deal with fear
that I found in my life, is a couple ways.
One of those ways is to turn it on itself
and ask yourself, "What am I afraid of?"
"I'm afraid of that?
"I got to be more afraid of
what I'm going to miss out on,
missing out me mission, missing out
on who I'm supposed to be."
In other words, if you're not
getting rid of fear, then use fear.
Use fear, or it uses
you, it's that simple.
So you got to say, "Okay, what's the price
"if I just stay doing
this, what's the price?"
I need to really, you can get scared
if I learn all this, and
I don't follow through.
That's something to be scared about.
And then that fear will get you
over your fear, it'll push you through.
Turn fear on itself.
Second way you can do it is use
what you've probably heard me say it,
'cause I've used it since I was 17,
is my little rocking chair test right.
I'm going to sit myself
on my rocking chair,
and I'm 85 years old and
I'm looking back on my life,
and I say, "I didn't
do this," or, "I did."
- If there was one
concept that I would
suggest to people to take a daily
confrontation with, it's fear.
The problem with fear
is that it lies, right?
So fear tells you, "Hey,
"if you say that to that girl,
"she's going to know she has you."
"And she'll never really
be attracted to you
if she knows how much
you attracted to her."
(laughter)
"Don't say that, no."
"How we get her is when
she walks by, ignore her."
(laughter)
- Right, it's this little
puppet on your shoulder.
- Fear tells you dumb
sh-- like that, right?
(laughing)
You know.
For me the daily confrontation
with fear has become
a real practice for me
since about three years ago.
I went sky diving
in Dubai, and skydiving,
skydiving is a really
interesting confront with fear, right?
So I got to stand up, I'm
sorry, I got to stand up.
(laughter)
Alright so, all your friends, what happens
you go out
- Hold this.
- Oh sorry, oh, I dropped my thing.
So what happens is you
go out the night before,
and, you know, you take a
drink with your friends.
And somebody says, "Yeah, we
should go skydiving tomorrow!"
(laughter)
And you go, "Yeah, we'll go
skydiving tomorrow, yeah, yeah!"
And you go, "Yeah!"
And everybody goes, "Yeah."
And you go home, you're by
yourself, you're like, "Mm."
(laughter)
Right, you're like "Well,
they was drunk too."
(laughter)
"So maybe, maybe they not, maybe ...
"I mean, we don't have to
go, we don't have to do it."
So then, that night, you're laying
in your bed and you just keep ...
And you're terrified, you keep imagining
over and over again
jumping out of an airplane,
and you can't figure out
why you would do that.
And you're laying there, and you have
the worst night's sleep of your life,
but you still have the hope
that your friends were drunk.
So you wake up the next
day, and you go down,
and you said where you were going to meet
and everybody's there, and you're like,
(laughter)
"Alright, alright, cool,
cool, cool, cool, cool, cool."
So you get in the van, and you don't know
that your friends had the
same night that you had
'cause they're pretending
like they didn't.
They're like "Yeah man,
my uncle's a Navy Seal,
"and, you know, this is going to be great.
"I've been looking forward to this."
And you like, "Oh my God, oh my God."
And your stomach is terrible,
you can't eat and everything,
but you don't want to be the only punk
who doesn't jump out of this airplane.
So you get there, and then
you have the safety brief,
and you're standing there
and the guys will tell you,
"Well, if the chute doesn't open,
what's going to happen is you do ..."
"Well, why the hell, what could happen ...
(laughter)
"That the chute wouldn't open?"
So you do a thing, and what you do
is your first jump
you're attached to a guy
who is going to, he's going
to walk you out, so you go.
And you get there, and
there's an airplane,
and nobody's stopping,
everybody's still going.
So you get onto the airplane,
and you're sitting there,
and it's extra 'cause you're sitting
on some dude's lap, some stranger.
(laughter)
And you're sitting on
his lap, and it's like
you're trying to make
small talk, "Yeah, man."
(laughter)
"So you be jumping with
people all the time, huh?"
(laughter)
Right, you know.
And then you just want to make sure,
"You got kids, right, you
got people you need to see?"
You just want to make
sure he's serious, right?
So you get in there,
so everything's normal.
So you fly and you go
up, you go up, you go up,
and you go up to 14,000 feet
and you notice there's a light.
It's red, and it's yellow, and green.
So right now the light's red,
so then you start thinking,
"At some point that
light's going to go green,"
but you don't know what's going to happen.
And you wait, and it goes
yellow, and the light goes green,
and somebody opens the door,
and in that moment you realize
you've never been in a frickin'
airplane with the door open.
(laughter)
Terror, oh sorry, I'm spitting, I'm sorry.
Sorry, no, terror, terror, terror, terror.
So you go, and then,
if you were smart you sat in
the back so you don't go first.
And then people start
going out of the airplane.
And you go, and the guy
walks you up to the end
of the thing, and you're
standing, and your toes
are on the edge, and you're
looking out down to death.
(laughter)
And they say, "On three!"
And they say, "One, two!"
And he pushes you on two
because people grab on three.
(laughter)
Right?
And you go ...
(laughter)
And you fall out of the
airplane, and in one second
you realize that it's the most blissful
experience of your life, you're flying!
It doesn't feel like falling.
You actually are kind of held
a little bit by the wind,
and then you start, you start falling,
you falling, and there's zero fear.
You realize that the
point of maximum danger
is the point of minimum fear.
It's bliss!
And you're flying.
(laughter)
Right?
And you're doing it.
And then 20 seconds,
25 seconds, 40 seconds.
And you have enough time
to just kind of be like,
"Oh, shit, that's that
building I saw like that one.
"Oh yeah, they see the ocean!"
(laughter)
You start doing all of that,
and the lesson for me was,
Why were you scared in
your bed the night before?
What do you need that fear for?
Just don't go.
Why are you scared in your
bed 16 hours before you jump?
Why are you scared in the car?
Why could you not enjoy breakfast?
What did you need that?
Fear of what?
You're nowhere even near the airplane.
Everything up to the stepping out,
there's actually no reason to be scared.
It only just ruins your day.
You don't have to jump.
And then, in that moment, all
of a sudden, where you should
be terrified is the most
blissful experience of your life.
And God placed the best things in life
on the other side of terror.
On the other side of your maximum fear
are all of the best things in life.